will his searching high and low on the
deck and down below but it's a cryin
shame no Jenny Dana gets to show off his
body for the comedy Hail Caesar and he
impressed his co-star George Clooney but
what about Channing's own little
two-year-old daughter our Carly feels
that Dallas bud boys just this morning
you said that everly cried when you were
singing to her actually yeah pretty much
she was a guy stop just don't do that
does it make you stop saying here you
just oh no that's a proud father go
harder Eddie I wouldn't I would never do
that Josh Brolin co-stars as a movie
studio fixer trying to get to the bottom
of his big stars kidnapping and his
comedy set in the Golden Age of
Hollywood but george hasn't fixing of
his own to do a malls birthday is in
just two days I've planned it all out
should I tell you everything and ruin it
I'm gonna surprise her with this amazing
day you could have chatting at tap dance
out of a cake firma that could be cool I
mean we've seen him so dangerous though
with all things I see uh yeah I don't
know what she really wants to see that
knows i'd like to stay married yeah yeah
it's just a pod because me and you might
what do you say I don't know cuz the
type I matter of it you say what you
never gave me in her it was easier you
should stay away from my wife and that's
all I'm saying stay away from my wife
speaking of which if Magic Mike three
were to happen what where do you think
George would fit into think you should
remember he fashioned mash
Magic Mike after me a little tequila and
me and next thing you know it's been
dollars applying I'm putting them
everywhere